thank you Mr President honorable members
of the parliament dear
commissioner the Belgian presidency of
the Council of the EU has taken note of
the measures announced by the commission
to respond to the demands of our Farmers
we have put the item of on the agenda of
the next meeting of the Agri Fisheries
Council which will take place on
February 26 to allow the minister of
Agriculture to express their views on
the measures proposed by the commission
as well as on the possible need for
further measures as the European Council
pointed out on February the 1st the
European common agriculture policy has
an essential role to play however the
rules adopted in 2021 to reform the cap
need to be reassessed to light in the
light of current
realities the proposals were initially
presented before covid and before the
onset of the war in Ukraine they
therefore require to be updated so that
we can strike an appropriate equilibrium
in our agricultural policy that is to
say we need to guarantee food security
and equally Fair remuneration for
Farmers we will need to take of course a
short-term approach but equally a
medium-term and strategic Vision in
order to ensure that we have sustainable
agriculture in the European Union in
every sense of the term that is to say
for the planet but also for those who
are involved in the sector thank you
very much for your
attention thank you very much indeed
Minister I now give the floor to M shich
on behalf of the commission vice
president you have the floor Mr
President Madame Minister honorable
members good morning to you
all we can be rightly proud of the
crucial role played by Europe's uh Agri
food sector guaranteeing food security
safety and quality not only for 450
million Europeans but for many others
around the world quite literally putting
save high quality food on our
tables while at the same time making a
massive contrib ution to the European
and global economy and striving to
contribute to the twin green and digital
transitions but while the sector has
shown remarkable resilience in the phase
of challenges such as pandemic and
Russia's war of aggression against
Ukraine we must ensure that our food
system is also fit for the
future with the green deal we have
already put in place an ambitious road
map to lead us to that future and yet
the reality of climate change
biodiversity loss growing resource
scarcity price shocks and an
increasingly competitive Global Market
is having a huge impact on the farming
sector and Rural
communities we have seen from the
farmers protesting on the streets of
Europe that many of them feel trapped
that their needs are not being
met so we must act to secure the future
of the sector and those who work within
it and those who benefit from it namely
all of us we have to ensure that the
Agri food sector remains competitive but
with decent incomes for all farmers and
smmes along the entire chain not least
to attract the next generation of young
Farmers all whil bringing the sector
within the planetary boundaries and this
means a future where farming and nature
go hand inand in balance views on how to
move forward are understandably varied
and we have seen increasing
polarizations on the number of topics it
is therefore imperative that we will
bring all the stakeholders together to
see how we can look for joint Solutions
and Define common vision and reach a new
consensus that is why we launched the
Strategic Dialogue on the future of
agriculture in the European Union and I
had the pleasure to discuss the dialogue
with the committee of Agriculture and
Rural depart development of this house
as well as with the
ministers uh in the Agriculture and
Fisheries Council ahead of its launch on
25th of
January the dialogue involves
participants from EU level associations
and organizations including umbrella
organizations representing a number of
European groups there are many reasons
which have driven Farmers onto the
streets in the past weeks and it's
important not to oversimplify the
situation because the problems of Agri
food sectors are complex there are those
whom the system serves well and there
are those who are being left
behind there are environmental Champions
and there are those who need our help to
become more sustainable there are those
who benefit from open trade and there
are those who are being squeezed by it
so that is why the Strategic dialogue
must cover all all the core questions
and involve all stakeholders and I
believe that we should focus on ensuring
a fair standard of living for farmers
and Rural communities supporting
agriculture within the boundaries of our
planet and its ecosystem we should
discuss how to exploit the huge
opportunities offered by knowledge and
technological innovation and how to
promote a thriving future for the eu's
food system in the competitive world
let me also highlight that our Farmers
continue being supported by EU budget
through the common agriculture policy
but we know that this money alone is not
enough to address the challenges we are
discussing today nor to deal with the
climate change let's look at the
devastating droughts in Spain the
apocalyptic floods in Greece Slovenia
Italy and elsewhere the forest fires
raging out of control so in action would
merely lead to even greater costs in the
coming decades such a disasters can only
be prevented if we have healthy natural
resources and only healthy soils clean
water and abundant pollinators can
protect high yields and Farmers incomes
in the face of climate and biodiversity
crisis Farmers know what they are doing
and I have seen this uh for myself
firsthand so our job now is to support
farmers in the transition helping them
the risk this necessary transformation
and scaling up all the good practices in
agriculture it is crucial to work with
the entire food chain so that consumers
can better appreciate the value of
sustainability our Farmers deserve to
make a decent living and that will only
happen if we work together to achieve
our climate and biodiversity goals I
know that the future of uh agriculture
is a complex topic for conversation
but I firmly believe that this strategic
dialogue will ultimately help us speak
with one voice of the common future we
will pursue for Farmers environment and
our Union as a whole so let's work
together let's discuss it thoroughly
also this morning I will stop here and
Mr President I very much look forward to
our debate thank
you we thank you very much indeed
commissioner we now move on to the
speakers on behalf of the political
groups May Manfred
bber
president
president vice president stevovic
Minister agricultural policy is at the
center of the debate today and that is
good because agricultural policy is not
subordinate to Environmental Policy it
is a policy area of its own we're
talking about the production of
wholesome food which is perhaps
something we take for granted but we
think it's extremely important and we
thank Farmers for what they do
agricultural policy is also about the
future of rural areas which is key to
the future of Europe we have major
challenges in front of us we as the
EP are in favor of biodiversity water
protection Animal Welfare protection we
must tackle the challenges of our time
headon but we cannot pursue ideological
policies we have to base our policies on
arguments and expertise in the Envy
committee
here they wanted to label wood as a
nonrenewable material that shows the
clear ideology
of policy and anyone who manages a
forest would have been shaking their
head when they heard that now of course
strategic dialogue is Paramount and
we're also carrying out dialogue outside
now many say they want to listen to
Farmers well 12 months ago we as the Epp
asked for a sensible debate on the capap
and we wanted a debate on the nature
restoration law and the temperature the
mood back then was quite different we
said that the sh initiative the
sustainable use regulation and the
nature restoration law we said there
were bad laws back then
now it would be wrong also to
impose the mandatory use of less
pesticides so that's why we said that
those legislative proposals went in the
wrong direction uh we have been
criticized pillared Peter Lea was
criticized very heavily by the head of
the Envy committee for our
policies and now
however others criticizing Brussels for
producing too much bureaucracy that's
what the French President is saying but
that's what we said a year ago now
Farmers know that we can depend they can
depend on us we will be their Advocate
we have fought hard yes we're in favor
of biodiversity protection yes we're in
favor of protecting the environment but
together with Farmers not against them
Garcia Perez the next speaker is Miss
Garcia
Perez
gra thank you president thank you uh
vice president president
shich now
I'm quite
surprised given that the agricultural SE
sector is up in arms right across Europe
and we're having an important debate on
it and we don't have the commissioner
for agriculture here it's not that he's
not here he doesn't seem to be anywhere
at all he's completely disappeared but
anyway let's talk about what he's
supposed to be responsible for Farmers
protests in the European Union have
shown us that the farming sector needs
the European Union just as the European
Union needs sustainable agriculture
because thanks to Farmers we have high
quality food and it's thanks to the
European Union that farmers uh have more
protection Vis are V the massive
challenges that they face such as the
increase in production costs and the
dramatic consequences of climate change
getting over the a farming crisis needs
to be done with the assistance of the
European and not via indiscriminate
attacks on the capap as have been made
by some European governments Hungary and
France for example let's not forget that
the latest reform of the C was adopted
by all national governments from all
political parties including Mr orban's
government the same man who is now
standing on tractors and regaling
everyone with populist
rhetoric the damage caused by Italian
and Spanish truck drivers in France are
intolerable the apology from the French
government is a positive gesture but
it's insufficient the commission needs
to adopt the necessary measures to
mitigate the costs that uh holers are
facing and to guarantee the free
circulation of goods ladies and
gentlemen we need more dialogue and less
polarization Farmers need to be aware
that the dispute between the right and
the far right is damaging to their
interests because the farri right are
not looking to increase farming
subsidies what they're looking to do is
renationalize agriculture which would be
devastating for European
Farms we need to talk to and listen to
Farmers the protest deserve a clear
response from the commission and member
states support to the agricultural
sector needs to maintain the
extraordinary direct assistance
particularly for those farmers who are
the most vulnerable to price increases
and the consequences of floods and
droughts it's also crucial to ensure
that the directive against unfair
commercial practices is implemented in
all member states because that would
help to improve the position of farmers
in the supply chain fair prices
simplifying bureaucracy is another me
measure that's necessary in a context of
increased regulations the first thing to
do is to identify which administrative
burden could be reduced because
simplifying doesn't mean no longer
complying it means complying in a
simpler Manner and if we want to ensure
that we have a new generation of farmers
it's necessary for all member states to
apply 3% of their CIP funds to get young
Farmers started in the profession ladies
and gentlemen the upcoming European
elections can't be used as an excuse to
include negation and protectionist
measures from some organizations that
are supporting the protests and who are
ignoring the demands of the majority of
farmers we absolutely can't accept the
problems in agriculture calling into the
question the goals of having agriculture
that's compatible with the fight against
climate change neither is it acceptable
for the European Union to sacrifice
trade agreements with third countries
what's necessary is to guarantee that
production that comes from third
countries is subject to the same
production rules that we apply to our
farmers in the European Union ladies and
gentlemen Agriculture and the
environment can go hand in hand and must
do so we need to work for to protect the
environment we need to be guided by
science we need to listen to the voices
of
farmers for the when it comes to the
next phase of the green deal and if we
do that the European project will
engender one of the best greatest
successes of the last 70 years farmers
are not the heritage of anyone let's get
to work and resolve their problems thank
you thank you very much the next speaker
is M Ur Müller president commissioner
Vice
President we are witnessing the most
major Farmers protest in Europe we've
ever seen in recent years and this is
because Farmers feel completely
overwhelmed by the S superfluity of
strictures measures and requirements
many of which are actually
contradictory they have falling incomes
and they simply feel feel that
politicians are patronizing them and
failing to engage strategic dialogue
president does show an initial awareness
of the issues at stake but the problem
is that the approach is completely
inappropriate topdown and um back room
deals is no way to connect to engage
with farmers who are taking to the
streets in
number we should far rather structured
Dialogue on the basis of regional
conferences which would bring together
farmers who could
participate in discussing the relevant
issues Regional experiences are very
important and if we extrapolate from
that the correct conclusions we could
come up with some genuinely constructive
conclusions which would deliver reform
for Europe this is what we are proposing
thank you very much Philip thank you
very much Philip
L if you listen to the extreme
right the conservatives the Liberals
well they say that the farmers Revolt
can be
blamed can can be uh blamed at the door
of the European green deal and the
environmental work karati but maybe
instead of stirring things up we should
look at we should listen to Farmers
because farmers are trapped between a
rock and a hard place on the one hand
land owners seed producers Agri chemical
Giants equipment manufacturers and Banks
then on the other hand you have Agri
business and
retailers but what has happened is that
farmers have been a bargaining chip for
years farmers are just receiving the
crumbs of the C 80% of the capap money
goes to Industrial Giants they shouldn't
even be called farmers and they are the
ones who say that they are the face of
farming it's as if Ikea said
it was an artisan Carpenter so it's
therefore no surprise that they are
pointing their fingers at the ca at the
green deal but the green deal isn't even
here yet you're blaming the green deal
but you are the ones who are responsible
you as the right were in favor of a
capap which is only about producing
which is only about merchandise you have
gutted the nature restoration law you
don't care about reducing greenhous gas
emissions or reducing pesticides but we
need the green deal if we are to survive
far farmers are at the front line of
climate change and they know this better
than you but we won't make any progress
without them let alone working against
them we won't make any progress if this
economic system causes them to commit
suicide these Farmers end up killing
themselves because they've been at it
for years and years you say that uh our
Environmental
Policy is punitive but your economic
system is punitive it's just in favor of
investors what your agriculture does
makes people sick it strips people of
their dignity and
freedom you are poisoning our air our
soil what's on our plates and our lives
on this planet your punitive economy is
something that we are fighting against
that we have been fighting against for
half a decade on Democratic ground our
Environmental Policy will help to
recover so that we can all live on this
planet so that we can live on this
planet which is the only one we
have the next speaker
is thank you thank you president
commissioner well I'm disappointed that
Mr timmermans isn't in your place he
seems to have done a
runner now for years we've been asking
you to listen to us we've fought hard in
spite of not having the numbers to stop
the green red Coalition that came up
with this crazy green deal every four
months you brought in another law
against farmers stock breeders fishermen
Etc and you said that we had to protect
nature from them and these are the
people who have been living and working
in the countryside for generations and
generations Farm to Fork you squashed
them with that and you promoted the
consumption of laa and insects then
Nutri scores you wanted to strike down
the Mediterranean diet then there were
regulations to stop Fresh Products being
being sold then you established
that vegetables couldn't be
called green or organic if they traveled
by lorri then you declared war on wine
and beef you then made
farming uh
equipment uh equivalent to Industrial
installations leftwing governments in
some countries even did away with the
subsidies for the purchase of diesel and
then there were the nature restoration
laws which saw you deciding that human
beings were destroying
nature we have to get rid of gravel in
rivers and then restore
swamps and uh if things had gone the way
that grea tumberg and others had wanted
then the CIP would have been even worse
and after all all of that what do you
expect from Farmers do you expect them
to say thank you they are the people who
haven't been listened to and now you're
trying to do a U-turn but it's too late
the minority has become a majority right
across Europe and in just a few months
we will put people in the place of
ideology Mr Mar the floor is
yours pres thank you very much indeed
indeed president a glass of wine is bad
for your health whilst insects are a
Panacea cheese is poison but chicken
could be good fishing is unnatural but
of course if you're flying the flag of
an EU member State possibly
not let's abandon organic cultures
entirely maybe let's stop growing
anything let's buy our cials from the
East because we need to leave our Fields
line follow the approach that this
commission has been advocating and
defending over the last 5 years is
completely schizophrenic and it's been
supported by a majority here in
Parliament it's completely hypocritical
in the face of war and in the face of
the many other
challenges for the policies that are
being pursued to be pursued and now
finally an alarm Bell is rigging loud
and clear throughout Europe the green
policy of Timberman and Fontan has been
an absolute an utter disgrace and it now
Falls to us both to correct it and to
change it we can't possibly run the risk
of having a par a continent which is
ever weaker ever more divided ever more
torn apart by these initiatives I agree
with Mr Lamberts at least in one part
the green deal is a disgrace but but
this is not the only reason that for
which the farmers are out in the streets
taking to the barricades for years the
policy pursued by the EU have created
this situation and on top of it we have
this disgrace of a green deal which have
meant that no farmers can even cover
their production C costs and this is
actually why they're taken to the
barricades and out in the streets it's
because they're very survival is at
stake that's why they're protesting
because they can't even make ends meat
from to month then of course there are
also political reasons too if you look
at the newspapers you don't necessarily
see all the ins and outs of it these are
Provisions though which have not simply
just come out of the blue they're ideas
proposals which have been put forward
deliberately by the political majority
in this house which supported the vland
Commission in this endeavor and this is
something which you have to stand up and
realize and we can't have a future for
the European Union which is based on
this because there are too many people
who are looking at the end of the month
with as much alarm as many would be
looking at the end end of the world
thank
you the next speaker
is we're supposed to feed
people but you leave us to die on our
Fields that's what I heard from Farmers
when I met last week when they were
protesting they feel as if they're being
left alone to die who is behind this you
you were against basic prices for
Farmers you
Swept Away an option which would have
reduced industry's profits you are the
ones who have signed free Trail
agreements which means that there are
unfair trading com uh trading
rules you come out with great speeches
for Farmers with your hand on your heart
but then you sign an a free trade
agreement with New Zealand so there will
be more honey wine meat cheese and dairy
coming from the other side of the world
and they are producing with pesticides
that we have banned hypocrisy Reigns we
in Parliament are the only group that
was firmly against all of these free
trade
agreements as if that weren't
enough there are two more that you voted
on last week with Chile and Kenya
respectively when will you ever stop
does our European farming Community have
to shrivel and die and don't say that
you have paused the mercur negotiations
no it continues and then there will be
Mexico Australia
India how can our Farmers be competitive
against Brazil or Ukraine which have
factory
farms what is the point of bringing in
goods from the other side of the world
when we can produce these wholesome
Goods on our own soil this is an attack
on fishermen and women
Farmers
Growers workers those who Feed Us day in
day out I recently met farmers who were
asking for for help in 2023 they hadn't
been able to sell anything these
beekeepers hadn't been able to
sell any of their honey they prep they
pref these supermarkets preferred to
Preferred to buy Russian honey Putin's
honey and so what are you going to say
to these farmers and beekeepers are we
going to continue with all this madness
Farmers can't won't be milked dry by the
industry and by your obsession
with signing free trade deals if we
continue on this path
then you will end our farming
sector the next speaker is Mr Dino
J colleagues
president European farmers are raising
their voices they're protesting it's
happening in Italy Belgium it's
happening here just outside this
building and there's a very simple
reason for
that they can make ends meet for years
decades we've
allowed
large distribution change chains to uh
destroy the prices that farmers
receive producers are producing at a
higher cost than they manage to sell
what they produce and that's the key
problem and I think it shows bad
faith when if people say that uh
protecting the environment goes against
Farmers no quite the opposite we need to
do that with Farmers because if we don't
farmers are going to face even greater
problems the truth is that there's a
problem that relates to prices un
International competition and trade
agreements and the EU shouldn't be
rethinking its Environmental Policy it
should be rethinking its trade policy if
it really wants to support Farmers every
European region needs to receive the
same contribution a sicilian farmer
currently gets a third less than other
Italian farmers and that's unacceptable
let's change these rules now Mr morisan
the Flor is
yours thank you very much Mr President
dear colleagues one of the greatest
achievements of European integration is
the quality of food in Europe people in
Europe trust food quality they trust
food safety and at the center of this
success is the European farmer this is
why we have the duty to listen to
Farmers in Europe This is why we have
the duty to support and to protect them
and of course agriculture in Europe is
modernizing agriculture in Europe has to
modernize and to reform as has every
sector of our economy as every part of
our society but we have to say clearly
we are modernizing agriculture with the
farmers not against the farmers and my
political family the Epp is ready to
work with the majority here in the
parliament to do the following seven
things for farmers and agriculture
firstly no decision on agriculture
without in to Farmers secondly no
decision without knowing the impact and
if there is any additional burden for
the farmers we have to be ready to
provide more support thirdly reducing
bureaucracy for Farmers Farmers have to
farm more than they report thirdly
secure the quality and the quantity of
food production in Europe we have to
produce more food in Europe not less
number five invest in the rural areas as
as a whole we want good schools good
hospitals we are ready to invest in
digiti ation in Greening but also in
infrastructure in the rural areas in The
Villages number six help in times of
Crisis if there is a crisis we have to
modernize the Europe we have to mobilize
the European tools that we have
including crisis reserves providing
financial support and number seven help
Ukraine help Ukrainian Farmers by also
helping our Farmers absorb what we can
in Europe help Ukraine to export the
other quantities to the other markets in
the world where they are needed we are
ready to work with a majority in this
house to achieve this for the farmers in
Europe thank you very
[Applause]
much and the next speaker is Clara
agil thank you very much president vice
president of the commission
colleagues we are facing a situation of
crisis in the farming sector farmers and
anal breeders are are taking to the
streets crying out to be heard they want
us to have a debate with them a proper
debate they have the impression that we
are simply undervaluing their
contribution to society wholesome food
high quality food environmental
sustainability rural cohesion all these
things are major contributions and they
feel that we're not recognizing this the
real problem is that we have to be aware
of the national Dimension but we've also
got to have a proper European policy our
tomatoes from Spain are excellent
despite what the french say5 per kilo is
what they cost but the producer is
getting 70 cents rather than5 and that
is the heart of the problem the fact
that the farmers are not getting
anything like a realistic price their
inputs are costs are escalating we are
getting cheap imports from third
countries and these are the problems
it's not just the green agenda which
does have positives this is really the
issue they don't have a fair income and
this is the responsibility of all of us
including the
commission you've mentioned vline you've
mentioned timbermans and started
castigating them you've also pointed out
that the commissioner for agriculture
hasn't even done us the courtesy of
attending the
[Applause]
debate next speaker is Mr confir
colleagues
well we can pass the
buck some say that environmentalism is
to blame some say the grand de the green
deal some say that retailers are to
blame no we need to take the sting out
of this debate and we need to boil it
down to three issues one income two the
green transition three the fight against
unfair competition and the need to
protect our farming sector can we do
that
can we compromise on the three issues
I've just listed if you want to
blame the green
transition and trade deals is pointless
and we can't have a green deal without
involving
Farmers because the biggest change to
far the biggest threat to Farmers and
incomes is climate change but if we we
need to uh Share value we do have a law
in front
that makes it easier
to uh Share value but that law is being
bypassed because of other European
countries so let's not blame each other
let's not try to find scapegoats but
let's try to have Solutions accept the
blue card yes madame oi
yes
Merc well thank you president Mr K you
said that
pointing the finger at free trade groups
won't change anything well you voted in
favor with your group with one of the
recent trade agreements the one with New
Zealand which for example is going to
include the import of 15,000 tons
uh 84 tons of beef and all these Goods
that I mentioned are produced using
pesticides like trazine which are banned
in the European Union but are allowed in
New Zealand so you really think that it
won't change anything for Farmers to
continue to massively import all these
products which contribute to unfair
competition do you
missy as you know when we
voted on that deal we most of us were in
favor of it including the snd and the
greens and that's because it contains
Clauses which will help deal with
climate change and some of the Clauses
and Provisions are favorable to our
farming sector however we are are
fiercely opposed to mercosur and Emanuel
macron last week spoke out clearly
against
mercosur if he hadn't done that we would
have mosur and we would have uh marur
because of ferine because of vber
because of the EP why don't you point
the finger at them the floor is yours no
no the second one is possible she no no
she don't us you don't us
no you don't ask Mr
J no I know the rules Mr
J I have no
intervention that's the rule Mr J solay
the floor is
yours gracias
presid it's just the rule and the rules
of
procedure but I give the floor to Mr J
solay so it was a mistake from my side
but he has the
floor no
problem farmers and livestock breeders
have many and good reasons to
demonstrate loss of
competitiv competitiveness problems with
exports but let's not make this mistake
the problem is not the green
deal as the conservative Coalition
constantly says with populist arguments
the problem is the economic structure
which is stacked against small producers
they're not receiving appropriate income
because we all know that with
appropriate income Farmers would be the
first the number one allies of the green
transformation and the reason that
they're not getting appropriate income
is the large retailers large groups that
oblig them to sell their goods at low
cost and also as a result of unfair
competition from Goods that come into
the European Union without complying
with the minimum requirements that EU
producers have to comply with and that's
a result of your free trade
agreements let's not be hypocritical
here let's explain the true reasons why
farmers are facing problems thank you
madame
thank you very much president uh Mr
commissioner ladies and
gentlemen we hear a lot of U beautiful
words you are worried about the fate of
European farmers who as you have
understood have not come to Brussels
last week or yesterday to Strasburg to
demonstrate and they have not been
protesting in Germany for many weeks
already there will be another protest of
farmers in Poland starting on Friday
they are not protesting in order to
present their support for your policies
quite the
contrary it is very quear to hear the um
Declarations of support for
Farmers when we hear them from the party
of Mr verber or the
Socialists who responsible for what is
happening now for the crisis in
agriculture for doing away with the
European agriculture people are Furious
because it does not pay back to produce
it is your responsibility of Miss V
Deion Mr timbermans you can only say
more beautiful words yesterday the
European
commission published uh a pro a draft to
uh curb um emissions by 9 % who will
gain on that yeah Yak
medicon thank you very much first of all
some uh colleagues say that let's not
accuse each other when we're looking for
problems concerning agriculture but I
have a
question if we don't blame each other
then you as if very conveniently want to
uh go over the real problems which have
been caused in agriculture and you do
your propaganda for 4 months before
elections uh want to attract all the
farmers and voters and you say that you
know best how to protect agriculture I
don't know how many of you were in the
European Parliament um in Brussels at
the the farmers meetings I was there I
didn't see any liberals or socialists
there I saw one communist but most
liberals they were sitting inside the
parliament but I was talking to the
farmers and they have the same problems
that conservatives have said for years a
green deal is uh destroying agriculture
because with Utopias and Fantasies you
want to save the planet if only 6% of
CO2 is caused in Europe but you want to
put this burden on farmers and others
and here in the audience you very
conveniently say how your standing for
Farmers but you are not doing this with
your idiocy you're just destroying
agriculture thank you very much is Mr
Luke fan
again farmers are protesting because
from their perspective the just
transition is just empty words they are
being required to meet ever higher
standards as they should and more needs
to be done but their livelihoods are
being undermined by imports from third
countries that do not meet the same
standards in Ireland the most
sustainable producers of beef the
suckler farm farmers are been paid to
reduce their stock while we import beef
from South America that is the other end
of the rainbow when it comes to
sustainability commissioner you talk
about help with sust sustainability
while incentivizing the destruction of a
sustainable beef production model the
hypocrisy of those supposedly supporting
the farmers needs to be called out the
Centrist and right-wing groups in the
European Parliament now extoling the
virtues of the farming Community are the
same people who drove the trade
liberalization agenda that has brought
us to this point every trade deal that
further undermined the position of the
food producer in the EU was
enthusiastically supported by and
championed by you and finally you are
wrong man Fred vber Farmers can't depend
on you on your watch food has been
reduced to a commodity to be traded
around the world exploited for profit by
multinationals instead of being valued
as an essential human right and those
who produce it being respected work you
don't do that and you're
not so Madame maret
pakas President commissioner colleagues
the agricultural crisis which we're
facing today is very serious absolutely
what we are experiencing is partly to be
attributed to the actions taken within
the institutions themselves the
initiatives taken by the commission and
this is why our French and other farmers
are so angry and those in the ultra
peripheral re regions are at least as
angry too much is being imported into
the European Union far too much
pollution is being generated and you are
simply swallowing the objectives of the
commission without questioning where
this is actually going to lead the Free
Trade Agreement ments which the European
Union is signing are
simply contributing to the hemorrhaging
of Agriculture on this continent it
should be a great wealth for Europe and
we should not be undermining it and
throwing out the baby with the bathat by
importing products from other third
countries we need to respect and support
Farmers because we depend on their
wholesome food
stuffs oh excuse me excuse me it was the
Mr
y colleagues what is sustainability what
is a sustainable
Farm it's when you can hand a farm down
from generation to generation so there's
an environmental part but there's an
economic part too a farmer has got to be
able to make ends meet why would a young
person get into farming why would you
you accept that you should be a farmer
earning less than someone working in an
office in nearly every EU country the
farming income is under the EU salary
average so we need to strengthen the
economic side of
farms if farmers are going to plow their
land if farmers are going
to grow if they're going to set land
aside if they going to look after
animals that should be their decision we
should leave it to
them and I
have I was expecting some uh proposals
from you today commissioner but I didn't
hear much from you now we need thriving
rural areas and that includes the
mountains I'm from a mountainous area in
Italy and what we've seen
there is that when farmers are up sticks
and leave then others follow them and
then these uh uh communities are eroded
so we need them to stay
there thank you Mr Dorfman Mr Jim now
please you thank
you colleagues friends without subsidies
many farmers would be making a loss this
is an untenable situation for farmers
and it's true of eggs apples cereals
Dairy sector this is their daily
reality Transporters
Bankers retail Industries are all
pocketing profits at the cost of the
farmers and it is absolutely High time
that we recognized that we can't be
defending the interests of those who
have at the costs of the farmers the
farmers have got to be Central to the
model for the future for Europe and this
is what the right has got to realize you
can't start blaming on the the on
climate change on the green deal on the
nature restoration directive we need all
these things for our farmer because they
need to have a good environment in order
to produce wholesome good quality food
that is what is necessary but they also
have got to be properly remunerated for
what they are producing and that is the
piece of the jigsaw which is missing in
this parli
thank
you president commissioner
colleagues Farmers have been turned into
useful idiots subsidies haven't gone up
for many years but uh equipment seeds
Etc costs a great deal
more but uh Farmers goods are still
Farmers produce is still being sold at
the same price as it was 10 years
ago you are stopping Farmers using their
land it's cheaper to bring in produce
from Ukraine and South America the green
deal as well uh Farmers have reduced
emissions by 22% in the US they've
increased by 6% in China 24% and in
Brazil they've gone up by almost
50% and you say that now you want to
talk to Farmers now that they're in the
streets but where have you been for all
these years shouldn't you have been
doing things acting thank
you the anchor of farmers today is
legitimate but answer me how can you
defend farming when you defend the
status quo which is wrong it destroys
Farmers it concentrates power in the
hands of a few and it makes our food
less healthy and makes food uncertainty
greater we've had enough of this enough
of this hypocrisy people who say oh
we're in favor of farmers but at the
same time you're in favor of free trade
agreements which strangles farming Mr
K you are the face of this hypocrisy
stop it you have trapped Farmers with
pesticides they are the victims of
pesticide use but they don't know how to
wean themselves off them today 20% of
farms gobble up 80% of capap funds and
you say that the environment is the
problem we need to fight back against
industry we need to fight back against
those who uh carry out tax evasion
who uh make huge amounts of money those
are the kind of things that we need to
change today thank
you FL is
yours thank you very much you should be
asking for forgiveness but you are not
doing so there is far too much derision
and Scorn heaped upon the agriculture
sector and farmers and for the last
several years this Parliament has been
voting in favor of the green deal you
have all been doing this colleagues and
you are simply voting in favor of trade
agreements bringing in all kinds of
imports in favor of imports from Morocco
and all this is undermining Spanish
agriculture this is the backdrop of the
past several years our workers on the
field are simply being sacrificed on the
altars of profit and this is completely
unacceptable Miss VLAN and her
colleagues have simply asphyxiated the
rural environment their initiatives are
simply massive redundancy plans for
agriculture and for millions of families
and you knew exactly all too well what
you were doing and yet you went on to
create these instruments which simply
sacrificed our producers on the altar of
your fine sounding green deals it is
high time that you tore up the green
deal thank you yeah excuse me excuse me
I have one blue card do you accept Mr do
you accept the blue
card thank you well Mr Bush you're
asking this house to apologize for
measures that have been taken by the
whole house to benefit the farming
sector and I'd like to ask you whether
you've asked your commissioner from your
political family the far right about
this cuzz he's not here in this debate
have you asked him to apologize for all
the things he hasn't done during this
legislative term I'd like you to
apologize for constantly instrumenting
uh using the farming sector what they
need is more Europe not less Europe as
you're calling for they don't need less
Europe as you
say farmers and fishermen need to be
helped
by measures that we adopt
here might I just reiterate that I did
not vote in favor of the green deal I
did not in vote in favor of the farm to
Fork strategy nor biodiversity nor any
of the trade agreements which have gone
through this house and are simply
bringing in masses of products from
third countries this is the Grim reality
you voted for them you you you you voted
for them I didn't we didn't and now
we're coming towards the elections
everybody wants to be friends of the f
but I can tell you you have a globalist
agenda and this is a an agenda like the
2030 agenda which is
absolutely
guaranteed to encourage and increase
import your minute is over ladies and
Gentlemen
please let's not go over the top in
terms of speaking time during this
debate I've let people go over their
speaking time a little bit but uh when
it comes to one a one minute time period
I can't give you more than five or 10
seconds extra because otherwise it's
unfair I have to treat everyone equally
and we're running late so therefore I'm
going to have
to do something about blue cards I can
only allow one question for one minute
when it comes to a blue card so please
let's stick to the rules let me now give
the floor to Mrs Limer
please once again Furious European
farmers are protesting in front of the
parliament in Strasburg as was the case
last week in Brussels do you need hay
slurry and eggs to be thrown at you for
you to wake up so we're not just talking
about suspending set aside rules
suffocating bureaucracy Merkur unfair
competition organic quotas livestock
bands
or PPP bands the list goes on the list
goes on it's not just about that farmers
are just fed up of your Ivory Tower
policy making with your green deal and
your handouts they don't want to be
caught up in your idiotic attempts to
save the climate and to turn them into
carbon Farmers industry can just up
stick and leave but Farmers grew up on
their land and they won't give up and
leave it and they won't be ignored
anymore
either
M Mr mcus now please uh vice president
commissioner I want to express
solidarity with family farmers who are
feeling the pain of inflation fuel costs
competitions with imports from outside
the EU and general lack of fair prices
these mounting challenges while they're
being asked to do more has reached a
breaking point for many who are more
concerned than ever for their family
Farm's future this was evident in the
anger scene last week but these protests
did not happen in isolation many of our
Farmers feel abandoned many have lost
fate in the system A system that has
burdened them with unfair free trade
agreements they can't compete with and
as rural custodians they are expected to
carry a large share of Green initiatives
like the nature restoration law they
must be duly compensated for such
efforts and concerns such as forry
wetting must be listened to and I call
on the Irish government in any future
National restoration plan to commit to
such issues gay
Galer thank
you thank you Mrs Tiana beging now
please thank you
president our Farmers income has
collapsed for two reasons essentially
firstly because they're suffering from
unfair competition from lowcost Products
that come from the other side of the
world and also because our industry
provides an advantage to large
distribution a kilo of apples is today
sold in supermarkets for not less than
two 10 cents but producers get just 29
cents that's the main problem the
environment has nothing to do with it
now for a long time the fstar movement
has been criticizing trade policies that
sacrifice agriculture we V oted against
CA that facilitated the import of
Canadian lowcost grain and we've always
been against the EU mercosur agreement
that would have damaged our fruit and
vegetable sector we need to hold our
hands out to Farmers and build fair
trade which is in line with their
interests it's only thus that we can
Safeguard our excellence and guarantee a
future to our Farmers thank yout Lin
thank you Mr Norbert Lind please
president president vice president it's
a good thing that farmers in Europe are
taking to the streets to protest at the
current policies it's often a question
of national governments taking the wrong
decisions my own government for example
which has failed to understand what the
rural communities are and has simply
pursued policies suitable for urban
communities but it is important for us
to take responsibility to the reality is
that we've got Tim's ideology driven
agenda behind all our policy initiatives
and we need to abandon that and shift
the dial back to a more realistic and
appropriate strategic
policy I am disappointed though that the
members of the farming Community are in
the streets demonstrating in the way
they are and we have nothing to propose
to them we've got to put a stop to so
many of the problems that they
experience we've got to cut red tape
we've got to ensure that they can
actually produce the products they want
that they have less bureaucracy that
they can actually produce the food that
we need and the things that they want to
produce stop Mr herin wait a moment but
I have a blue card from Ro Bron but but
I would ask you you are also on the list
of catdi what is your priority the blue
card or catdi
the blue card
good please take your
question thank you Mr President
colleagues indeed you have already
mentioned that but legal acts
regulations and directives allow member
states to make the conditions even
stricter and to
uh impose stricter regulations what is
your opinion shouldn't member States pay
for this shouldn't we include a
provision that if a member State imposes
stricter conditions that increase
expenses bring in their own money there
thank
you thank you very much for that
question I have every
sympathy with the need for for European
legislation to be one in one out and I
do understand of course that
transposition International
legislation sometimes requires Regional
governments involvement as well and it
can go beyond what was legislated for in
the EU but if you're talking about
leaving landow this is something which
we are had initially proposed should be
4% we really can't just keep passing the
back and take and the cost is always
borne by the farmers thank you Mr
dcastro
please president
shich president uh commissioner uh
colleagues now for 20 years we have
ensured that our agricultural sector is
the best in the world in terms of
sustainability respecting uh workers
rights Etc but the current parliamentary
term has has moved from pursuing
Excellence to pursuing ideology and we
don't have any plan to support farmers
in the transition towards new productive
models this Parliament however has tried
to listen to rural communities working
to find clear and balanced
Solutions far better ones than those
that have been Pro proposed by the
commission also just
recently we need to reestablish the link
between the EU and our farmers and in
order to do that we need to give them
ownership of a project that provides
Innovative tools based on Sustainable
New
biotechnologies so that we can ensure
that we can achieve ambitious
environmental goals and make our sector
more competitive at the global level
thank
you thank you very much uh Mr dcastro
good morning colleagues good morning
commissioner and now Mr kattin you have
the
Flor president having been a farmer
myself I know that you leave a farm to
the Next Generation in a better shape
than it was when you received it as
decision makers we have to behave in the
same way and do our utmost to improve
the competitiveness and attractiveness
of the Agricultural sector there is a
limit to how much more we can demand
from Farmers without guarantees of a
livelihood ultimately it boils down to
the to food Security in the whole of
Europe comprehensive impact impact
assessments are needed as well for
present legislation as for incoming
regulations we have to avoid overlapping
legislation and administrative burden
furthermore we will have to assess the
directive on unfair trading practices
its Effectiveness in the member states
and how to further reinforce the
directive so that the position of farmer
in the food chain can be improved
Farmers have to get a better price for
their produce and we have to stick to
the C
financing I hope that the commission
will take Farmers distress seriously in
its fut future
proposals the next speaker is Mr
hling
colleagues I have a lot of sympathy
for Farm who are protesting we don't
need to burn anything
there but things are terrible prices are
falling and the final blow the final
blow is the difference between the farm
gate price and the the price that can
that retailers sell at we need to deal
with
that farmers depend on subsidies now and
that can't continue LT Nobert lince let
me respond to you say a few words about
the capap you've ensured that 2third of
capap money is landbased area based the
big Holdings continue to get a lot of
money and now you Norbert Lind say that
this was the biggest capap reform since
Sherry since MC Sherry and now you're
saying it's a bad
reform you always celebrate when
environmental measures are scrapped but
no environmental measures are needed if
you are in favor and celebrate uh the
removal of environmental measures then
you are against
farming thank you the next speaker is Mr
boura thank you very much
indeed colleagues the EU treaty
guarantees that the farmers have the
right to a reasonable standard of living
but this policy is failing our farmers
are entitled to get a proper price for a
good quality
product but our family farmers are
powerless in the market especially Visa
the big players in the food production
chain the commission has got to provide
now some guidelines to ensure that
farmers can actually operate on a basis
of some kind of legal certainty and a
system which involves them in price
setting we have to realize colleagues
that sustainability is not just
ecological but also
economic the commission has produced an
absolute Avalanche of rules completely
at variance with the principle of
proportionality you need to review this
there needs to be a proper impact
assessment both at Regional and at local
level as well as National level and the
farmers have got to have entitlement to
a proper income and proportional rules
thank you the next speaker
is no Mr
go thank you president well our farmers
are in a d dramatic situation and that's
the result of political choices that
have been made in Brussels and voted on
here in
Strasburg the free trade agreement with
Chile voted on in committee two weeks
ago is an example of that and the pr
macron forces are voting in favor of
them now quite asart from the distress
that our farmers
face this is a crisis of
society farmers are passionate about
their jobs and they have often been
working their land for Generations they
have a clear link with nature and
traditions and they want to pass this on
to their children this is a traditional
ancestral world that has forged society
and this goes fully against what the
European Union wants to impose on us
with the form of society which is ultra
liberal and globalist and that's why the
crisis that Europe is is facing is
something that will continue and it's
because of that that support for our
Farmers is massive and that's why macron
is afraid he's using the military police
with armored vehicles to stop tractors
but this is a popular Revolt it's quite
right for them to be revolting and it's
based on values that have lasted for
Generations
there are two opposing models here and
on our side we made our choice a long
time ago everything shows that we are
right thank
you thank you I have a request from Mr K
to have a blue card but I also have a
lot of others too and therefore Mr kicho
I would prefer to ask you just to take
the floor later on at your appropriate
point in the speaker
list well
well the leadership in Brussels is on
the wrong path we should have Mrs Von
delion here actually she is ultimately
responsible for all this stuff war in
Ukraine migration farming agricultural
policy it's clear that Brussels is being
LED and doing things on the basis of
ideology it doesn't have the interest of
the people at heart now these green
measures are ruining European farmers
and Brussels is bringing in cheap Europe
Ukrainian grain which is flooding
European markets and is also negotiating
free trade agreements which
put non-european countries in a better
position than European countries what
kind of policy is
that Brussels
is going along in the false in the wrong
direction and is benefiting our
competitors the US and China are
implementing protectionist measures we
should do the same the Brussels
leadership need to work in favor of
European citizens and give up its
ideology based policy it's time for a
change in Brussels thank
you thank you please would you respect
your speaking time colleagues the next
speaker is Mr Zoo
thank you very much indeed thank you
president last week many people were
alarmed to see what was going on in the
square and the streets outside
Parliament full of tractors and
protesting Farmers the commission has at
least capitulated to some small extent
in the face of the demands of the
farmers and has said that it will review
some of the most extreme Provisions in
the green deal and we welcome that but
we do also feel that there is still a
lot of work to be done to deal with this
Legacy of Mr Timberman we have to
protect the farmers and the breeders in
Europe and we've got to have much more
flexible
criteria to on which the C is based
clearly we have to address drought
clearly we have to have mirror Clauses
to deal with unfair
competition that in itself will not be
enough but it's at least if we begin
with that that we will get
somewhere Mr Zer there's a blue card for
you from Zina who doesn't Miss V who
doesn't actually have a place on the
speaker list and therefore I should give
her the
floor thank you I'll just let you put
your headphones
on
right thank you
uh thank you for what you've just said
but it was your party that is in FA
favor of the capap and landbased
payments these are industrial measures
you're in favor of these industrial
measures this means that small farmers
aren't on a Level Playing Field now
you're criticizing environmental
measures but what's your
alternative on S on the pesticide
reduction issue these pesticides affect
our soil our water make them
less able to produce and this isn't what
people want please wake up and listen to
what Society is saying to what farmers
are saying so that they don't have to be
dependent on these expensive
inputs so if you want a concrete
question do you agree with me or not we
need to protect farmers do we
not thank
you first of all could I say that the
European people's party is quite clear
that we need to continue to improve the
quality of our products we need to
tackle climate change and we need to do
so on the basis of evidence-based policy
not ideology that's the first thing and
there's no point in beginning with
ideology when you're dealing with
Technical and scientific reports could I
also say that I think what Mr timbermans
has said and done is very very very
serious the farm to Fork strategy was
presented to us without the technical
report on which it was based and this
included a lot of information which had
we had it would have changed the
parameters considerably and would have
shown how much the input costs were
going to escalate and the fact that we
wouldn't necessarily achieve the quality
which we wanted and that we would have
many challenges from lower quality
products from out with the EU the EP
wants a focus on Farmers their demands
are absolutely right and just and it's
high time that they were treated with
respect and not simply as some kind of
ideological
add-on colleagues could I please call
you to order and ask you once again to
respect your speaking time
M dear
colleagues the first thing I want to say
today is that I express solidarity with
Farmers particularly young
Farmers regardless of their member State
these farmers are fighting for something
simple dignity recognition of their way
of life they're fighting for a decent
income from an activity that we all
depend on and they're also fighting for
Less red tape when accessing funds I
also want to pay tribute to small
farmers small livestock producers
there's a lot of them in Europe but
often they find it difficult to access C
funding so that fight this fight belongs
to them this is not the fight of the
right or the far right the right
proclaims to be the savior of farmers
but the right actually polarizes the
debate and pits Farmers against each
other so this fight belongs to the rural
World rural communities deserve respect
and we need to come up with measures
that will help farmers so that they can
become more sustainable
these Farmers love their
land and we mustn't pit Farmers against
nature thank
you Mr
chos over the past few weeks the farmers
have taken to the streets in many
European countries because they have
lost their patients the causes are well
known the energy and post-pandemic
crisis the war in
Ukraine and
the impact um of the green policies uh
without calibration in agriculture how
can we overcome this situation how can
we align the European Ambitions with the
capacity of the farming sector to adapt
all the discussions about U supporting
the farmers uh on the short term make no
sense unless we draw some conclusions
from the mistakes we have made over the
past few years we really need a project
that includes the need for affordable
and healthy food and the need for a
clean uh environment but also reasonable
and predictable incomes for the farmers
we haven't uh done this well enough so
far and we can already see the results
in an unpredictable context for the
farmers uh the derogations of the
commission on the short term are good
but they will not solve the problem on
the long term the role of the commission
is crucial over the following uh weeks
and months in order to make decisions
that send a clear signal signal it is
capable to listen to the farmers
concerns for a fair income in order to
take into account the environment and
food production thank you Miss
mitz dear president dear commissioner
our food system is broken multinationals
are making billions while Farmers
struggle to make ends meet extremely low
prices Family Farms disappearing every
day we are in an agricultural crisis
through the farmers protesting outside
we are not your enemy we greens know
that without Farmers there is no food
and that farmers deserve to make a
decent living we all also know that
without nature there is no farming what
has led to this crisis are the policy
pushed by the very people who like to
blame us greens more and more free trade
agreements and un Fair common
agricultural policy and simply not
enough support to help farmers through
the transition here is what we need to
do stop unfair competition from imported
food break the power of big Corporation
more support to small farmers less
bureaucracy let's give Farmers workable
solution that protect nature without
bwing farmers in paperwork thank you
very
much thank you very much the next
speaker is Mr
Rose the farmers protests are continuing
throughout the entirety of Europe as we
can see the green deal was created by
France timans in order to make life
impossible for farmers in Europe and the
Jewel in the crown was his nature
restoration act uh finish off the
Netherlands now the Dutch people last
now you can see once again the farm are
taking to the street and the Christian
democrats are suddenly wakening up to
reality and chucking all these
anti-farmer proposals into the waight
paper basket but they've been supporting
all these ideas for the
last president commissioner today
farmers are at the heart of our
debate alas apparently we didn't see
this Crisis coming well on the left
here the max cron supporters turned a
blind eye and we have just gone for more
and more regulation then if we look at
the national rally and the extreme right
they're absent but we in the EP have
long spoken up for the farming
Community being the mouthpiece talking
about their despair but now we must
urgently act we need to press pause on
new rules and regulations we need need
to have mirror Clauses we urgently need
to simplify the C we may need to look
again at the 4% set aside rule we must
act so that we can ensure food security
throughout the
continent there's a blue card from you
from Miss Garcia
mun well thank you
president the legitimate protests of
farmers
have led to disputes between uh French
farmers and Spanish Lorry Lorry drivers
transporting Spanish goods and this is
worrying now we need to maintain the
single market and also we're concerned
about uh Lorry
drivers now is the right way for French
Farmers to be throwing Spanish Goods out
of lorries I mean is the French
government going to allow this to
continue to happen shouldn't France take
the responsibility for its own
agricultural policy thank you France our
farmers are dealing with additional
problems because of so-called gold
plating
but should we have the same rules
throughout
Europe we see that farmers don't comply
with the same rules they don't have the
same rules which leads to
further problems and that means that
farmers aren't on an equal footing let's
ensure that the rules are the same
within Europe but also in the rest of
the
world Mr clure
please
colleagues the environment is not the
enemy of Agriculture the enemy of
Agriculture is liberalism liberalism has
led to a reduction in Farmers Revenue
Farmers income income income income that
should be what's at the heart of our
debates and in order to do that we need
a capap that's different because uh
unpredictable and deregulated markets is
a system that doesn't work but we can
change the
implmentation of the capap by putting a
ceiling on assistance on Aid to help
smaller farmers and we can also fight
against the deregulation of the markets
and speculation there needs to be a
redistribution of value which guarantees
income for Farmers we need to suspend
free trade
agreements and bring mirror Clauses and
the CC a cbat uh in and we also Mr
Christenson
please my my and we have to recognize
that there is huge financial
uncertainty and economic and social
uncertainty amongst Farmers fuel inputs
have
risen the environmental constraints are
greater the levies are taking their toll
on the farmers we understand all this
it's high time that we took some time
out of course environmental change is
necessary but all this has
simply taken place at a place at a pace
that is unrealistic there's far too much
red tape bearing upon the farmers and as
UL of Wonderland said herself there
should be a 25% cut in red tape and
there needs to be a review to make sure
that we find the right Solutions Green
Solutions yes but realistic solutions
for
Farmers we have of course to ensure that
biopesticides can be approved improved
more rapidly so that they can be used
rather than others and implementation
enforcement is of course key thank
you Mr Vander cand
please
commissioner president how many times
have we debated the conditions that
we're going to impose on Farmers over in
recent all the protests that are
breaking out of course we need to have
climate policy but we've simply it's
degenerated into a plethora of rules and
we've basically placed the farmers hands
tied behind their backs battling with a
brutal Global
Market we have supported industry and
we've supported other policy areas but
not Agriculture and food production as
far as I'm concerned strategic
agricultural dialogue ought to lead to
an agricultural Protection Law and this
should be based on fundamental criteria
which could have a bearing on food
security I'm thinking for example of
availability of quality soils of
bringing more young people into the
farming sector Innovation being able to
get proper prices for your products
availability of water and so forth
Farmers have to be in the central place
that they deserve thank you thank you
Mrs abam now
please in the title of today's debate we
find an interesting word
Fair what's fair when the value of grain
in the EU has decreased by 30% the
commission comes up with a derogation
obliging farmers to double the surfaces
that are object to new environmental
conditionalities Farmers say but that
will double our losses because we know
very well that some of the crops that
were recommended to plant won't survive
without without pesticides others need
lots of water in summertime when there's
usually a
drought the commission constantly tries
to patch an Ever unraveling tapestry
it's really difficult for us to
understand why even now it's still
unclear that for Farmers fair means
something that's decided together with
them not without them now this might
sound absurd but for new ambition you
need new
money thank you Mrs
please
colleagues there are loud farming
protests throughout Europe but that
sends us a message farmers are desperate
to be heard complex
requirements uh Investments unfair
competition all of this means that
farmers are grappling with greater and
greater challenges but let let's be
clear the farming sector is
disappearing and there's less
money but I have said on many occasions
that we need appropriate funding let's
do that
today now on the subject of red tape and
red tape
production there needs to be action
following in the footsteps of promises
we need need to work with Farmers so
that they can then solve their
problems commission representative
council the issue
of
payments and the same payments for
everyone needs to be looked at so that
uh there's more money for uh Bulgarian
Farmers please stick to your speaking
time because otherwise we're not going
to be able to hear from well I'll catch
dear
colleagues
these policies have brought the sector
to the to its knees uh whatever measures
we discuss uh we won't do anything
unless we really make the changes that
need to be made commissioner you came up
with a derogation but it doesn't solve
the problem because the crops that are
about to be planted would cause damages
rather than benefits we ask for money
for the crisis Reserve now at the last
minute we ask you to simplify the PAC
rules the cap rules a farmer cannot
understand how someone from Brussels can
tell them when to plant or what to do
with their
land I ask all of you to be honest
Partners to our Farmers not to turn the
Brussel politicians into a risk factor
for
farming because that's what you're doing
today if you promote environmental
policies without listening to Farmers
thank you Mr ke Janis
[Applause]
please ladies and gentlemen dear
colleagues the
C which is the most successful EU policy
during the last 30 years what do our
Farmers claim a decent income reduction
of the fuel and uh Power cost they want
to top up the to restore the losses of
their income yes they are right what do
they
contribute and a guaranteed security of
uh
food and provision of food so we
need a strategy for that I propose the
creation of a new fund for the fair
transition to support the income of
farmers just as we did with the green
deal yes we are in favor of the
protection of climate but always on the
side of European
thank you Mrs Neer now
please well thank you
president vice president Council
representative ladies and gentlemen well
for weeks now Farmers have been on the
streets quite rightly too much is too
much they've had enough when it comes to
agricultural policy our line has always
been that we're going to CRA craft
policy with Farmers rather than against
them now we ensured that the
because there are so many people who've
asked for the floor that we just haven't
got time so anyone who's had a blue card
intervention won't be able to take the
floor Mr bogovich
please thank you very much for the
floor in Spring of last year I joined a
Slovenian farmers who started protesting
these protests were aimed against
measures coming from the EU back then we
realized what the sustainable use
regulation and the nature recovery
regulation meant we together protested
against those measures for the first
time I protested against the EU measures
because we went too far the Slovenian
farmers were protesting against the
measures by the Slovenian government
these Slovenian measures only
strengthened and worsened certain
European measures that had not been yet
adopted in the European Parliament this
same government selenian government
wants to limit the use of wood for
heating in rural areas farmers are
protesting also against the current
Supply chains and distribution chains we
have to listen to the farmers we have to
find common Solutions not just
discussing at at added value
burden that was a cas
well we
Face a clear truth here I mean had
Farmers been respected if their work had
been respected
well we probably wouldn't have seen all
these demonstrations right across Europe
the latest ones in Brussels and
Strasburg now the problem is not the
green transition or the need to preserve
the environment because actually it's
farmers who are the first ones to
protect the environment they live off
the environment the choice problem is
the
ideological environmental choices that
are being made they're not based on
scientific evidence they're not
providing an alternative and they're
causing problems for an entire economic
system
so our path can't simply to be to go for
lab grown
meat or not Gathering crops because uh
they shouldn't be
harvested we should respect the
environment yes but we should also
respect farmers and their work thank you
Mr y now
please president vice
president shouting in the
room
but we have we press the button at first
that's your problem I stay since the
beginning of the me just a
minute I also pressed a button in the
beginning I
know
I'm I'm going to give you the floor Mrs
vman you will get the floor we're going
bip political group and as you can see
we you will get the floor
we're moving in political group order
please be patient let's stay
calm and let's hear from our speakers Mr
y
please president vice president the
commission is saying the following we
want to support
Farmers but Farmers feel looked down
upon rather than being a solution and
now you're saying that theu structural
dialogue forum is going to be the
solution but it really has to work this
time there needs to be
trust and that would include suspending
the set aside rule dur as long as the
war in Ukraine goes on change the basic
act and get rid of this set to side
requirement then there needs to be a
program which buys up Ukrainian grain
then we export that grain to North
Africa so we need open structural
dialogue which focuses on providing
Solutions thank you Mrs graini
please Madame President commissioner
dear colleagues we have a key uh
priority with the farmers in the street
and the agriculture commissioner is not
here how can we debate on priority
topics for agriculture if the
commissioner is not here thank you uh um
vice president for being here the
president is not here either because she
doesn't participate in priority debates
dear colleagues we need solutions to
these problems we are proud of the
Agricultural sector but are they proud
of us for what we do for them
commissioner we said we must find
Solutions but the solutions are clear
during the crisis we have to increase
the budget we must urgently revise the
capap uh we speak about fairness but uh
ities are not equal in all member states
we speak about fairness but in the
Netherlands they consume 8 gram per
hectar in U of pesticides whereas in my
country the consumption is
600 we cannot speak about uh fairness um
if we eat locusts and uh insect meal uh
Farmers uh want natural agriculture
consumers want the
same
thank you
Mr we need to recognize that Miss Von
has not had the courage of any
convictions and she has not stayed here
for this debate we have seen many
protests on behalf of the the farmers
and of course the reality in this house
is that everybody's looking to the
elections in June the farmers are
pressurizing members of parliament the
members of parliament want to be
reelected okay the farmers are not a
very large percentage of the population
but we can't use that as a reason to
ignore their demands because their
demands are actually more than well
Justified they have great
difficulties in the normal course of
events but the repercussions from the
Ukraine war have been huge for them and
the escalation in their fuel and inputs
cost have been a big struggle for them
to deal with on top of that they're now
threatened with all the trade agreements
which have been signed and the floods of
cheap sub quality Goods which are going
to be coming into the European Union I
welcome the fact that the commission has
at least decided to suspend the uh thank
you you Mr Olas please stick to one
minute because otherwise we won't be
able to give everyone the floor
please uh thank you president honorable
vice president representatives of the
council I'm happy that you heard the
demands of the farmers when they came
with the tractors and now are beginning
a strategic dialogue but what are your
words and commitments worth if you don't
fulfill them when Lithuania was joining
the EU back in
2004 uh we were told that external
convergence direct payments will be
evened out in 10 years now 20 years
later there's no external convergence
therefore I'd like to call upon all of
you and to draw and to fulfill our
promises we first of all must fulfill
the promises given we must fulfill the
commitment our commitments to the Baltic
and Lithuanian farmac and only then
solve other problems thank you Mrs vman
now vman's now please and uh let me just
say thank you Madame President I'm glad
that we've had this debate here this
morning and indeed yesterday morning we
also discussed what the farmers are
demanding they are taking to the treat
saying listen to us listen to us we
can't continue to live like this we
can't eek out any sort of live living
the Belgian presidency under Alexander
deu and USR clearly recognized last week
in Brussels that something had to be
done and they took some steps to getting
rid of some of the red tape and also the
obligations to leave some of your land
line follow I think that most of the
groups can support this but we need to
go further the other thing that is
absolutely necessary and I remember you
saying Mr B we've got to have an impact
assessment we've got to have an imp
impact assessment of all this whole
lasagna of legislative Provisions that
have a bearing on Farmers we've got to
look at unfair competition for example
we've got to look at all the other
aspects of policy which take a toll on
farmers and give them the respect they
deserve thank
you thank you Mr viik gra uh
well Farmers uh need help and we need
effective solutions to help them so
appropriate prices ensuring Fair
competition we need to look at the
effects that Imports are having I mean
let's not use the wrong arguments here I
mean we've heard an awful lot of things
here today I mean people saying that uh
protecting the environment goes against
Farmers interests I mean we've heard all
sorts of
things the commission has acted in
certain ways as well uh on set aside we
need to deal with that and uh we also
need to make sure that uh critical
species continue to be be to to exist
but also we continue to produce the
produce that's necessary so we need to
act against all the things we're hearing
that aren't
appropriate it seems that here in this
chamber everybody is on the side of the
farmers good for them but where were you
in 2020 when we environmentalists were
saying that you should reject the
mercosur agreement or where were you in
2021 when we said that the new capap
would require more resources for farmers
and less for Agri
business now you're climbing over each
other shoving each other out of the way
to get photographs with the
demonstrating farmers and their tractors
but what are you doing about agre
business if you really want to support
Farmers then you need to put forward
some proper proposals you need to tax
Agri business and massive retailers who
are operating to the detriment of
farmers you need to reject the
Merkur trade agreement and you need to
address the
whole sub supply chain in the farm
sector you can't have a sector which is
operating to the benefit of 20% of mass
retail and nobody
else Mr
please thank you very
much look at the political Spectrum
we've criticized everyone else on the
political spectrum and said what you're
doing to farming can't continue now it's
the final straw that will break the
camels back now farmers are in the
street but you won't change direction
you have overburdened Farmers with too
many rules and regulations there are too
many restrictions under your green deal
you have cornered farmers
with a flood of goods coming in from
outside the EU you've also placed
restrictions on them meaning they can't
use synthetic and mineral fertilizers as
much they're not getting the same
subsidies for their fuel and now you
think that they're going to be able to
buy e
tractors electric
tractors and then people are cut off
from EU funding for LGBT reasons so are
you going to end uh production in Europe
I hope you are thrown out at the next
elections thank you well the Green
Revolution wants to change Farmers
Fields into fields of solar panels so
that we can have energy to produce
synthetic food this is the crazy reality
of what's Happening tractors have been
outside the European Parliament just for
a few days but you've been laying Siege
to Farmers for years now you've signed
free trade agreements that have opened
up the single Market to products from
third countries that don't have our
standards some of you accus us of having
of having voted in favor of the C but
it's the only instrument we have to
support Farmers if we hadn't voted in
favor they would have been struggling
leftwing and green members who didn't
vote in favor of it but it wasn't to
support farmers it was because they
didn't think the CIP was green enough it
didn't damage Farmers enough I am proud
of the fact that I voted against the
crazy Provisions linked to the green
deal which really bring European
production to its knes not only farming
prodction you've forgotten European
workers but European workers won't
forget you you can be sure of that thank
you Mr per
please thank you president farmers are
protesting throughout Europe but there's
one thing they've all got in common the
common agricultural
policy you might want rapid change but
this has been a terrible
policy it means Aid is unfairly
distributed 70
80% of Aid goes to just 7% of farmers so
as long as that continues there will be
Injustice Portuguese Farmers have spoken
about the lack of support for small
farmers and mediumsized Farms this means
that they're struggling as costs
Skyrocket as their yields and income
goes down and on top of all that there's
a drought we must show solidarity with
Farmers including those who are
demonstrating in Villa real all of this
means we need to urgently alter the
capap we need to have Market management
measures we need to ensure food
sovereignty for everyone thank you Mr
tabella European and Belgian Farmers
have been Express saying when I hear
what Shan bellaa is saying and the
extreme right is doing in voting for The
CP that we have I can see how far the
hypocrisy has gone you voted for this
cap and it exacerbates the discrepancies
disparities between small farmers
and the massive Farm
the reality is that we are partially
responsible for the situation in which
Farmers find themselves in and the way
we have funded and promoted large scale
farming we need to have a policy which
is based on a radical rethink of imports
for example from Latin America we need
mirror Clauses governing the dairy and
beef Imports
and thank you Mr tarabella um we have to
stop catch the here we took 13 speakers
out of 24 taking account of the size of
political groups the next debate starts
at 11: but we've still got the
commission and Council to take the floor
colleagues unfortunately so Mr sovich
please micro please
please please okay mer no no no no
no no I'm afraid you can't take the
floor unless it's a point of order or
something but uh I'm afraid you can't
take the floor into catch the ey the
catch the ey procedure has been
concluded we tried to balance the
different political groups catch the is
now concluded the floor now goes to vice
president schich
please and we asked for the floor right
at the beginning we have responsibly
listened to the entire debate we stayed
here out of respect for the
institution the speaker's microphone is
cut off
[Applause]
please
please as we said right at the start
please please let me explain as we said
right at the start it wasn't possible to
take all requests for the floor because
we had 24 of them so it wasn't possible
to take them
all political groups are of different
sizes and then therefore we based
ourselves on the size of political
groups when we took speakers so we took
three PP three socialists one from renew
and then one from the other groups that
was a decision taken by the presidency
because the next debate begins at 11:
please vice president cheich
please vice president
please yes M thank you
thank thank you very much uh Madame
President Madame Minister honorable
honorable members of the European
Parliament first and foremost I would
like um to thank uh all of you for
having addit this key debate at the
level of political leaders and I think
that this debate clearly demonstrated
that our Agriculture and Rural
communities are affected by wide range
of policies several crisis and current
geopolitical tension and therefore I'm
glad that I could have participated in
this debate on behalf of the European
commission you honorable members uh
clearly uh highlighted how complex issue
we are going to uh discuss today
especially in these uh challenging times
for for Europe and Farmers but I think
what is absolutely clear also after this
uh morning exchange is that that what we
need is to work better uh together that
we need together look for uh
constructive Solutions and I think as
Madame Garcia Perez mentioned it early
on in our discussion Farmers needs EU
and EU needs farmers and I would like to
ensure all of you and especially our
farmers and Foresters community that we
treat them with the utmost respect and
appreciation for the work and that they
will continue to do so also uh in the
future
I think that uh um now clearly it's a
time to work on how can we overcome the
polarization which got into our
discussion what we can do to build
Bridges and I cannot find a better place
like this house to start with this
process to build the bridges to look for
the uh for the common common Solutions
and to have a right focus on our
discussions for the future and how to do
it in the best possible way is to
propose and work on the Concrete
Solutions and many ideas been already
mentioned here uh today and also as
Madame wman said yesterday in our debate
with the president of the European
commission what I kind of record and
recall that all of you called uh for
making sure that we have to address one
crucial point and this is how to uh
guarantee decent income for our fers how
to make sure that those who produce in a
sustainable manner who are treating
their employees decently who respect all
environmental forms will not be
under alternative imports from abroad
and that's something what we are clearly
looking at and what we want to address
Mr muresanu Mr Weber and many others
have have been calling uh for uh making
sure that we will not take the the
decisions on agriculture without talking
to the farmers and we are doing exactly
that therefore we launched our strategic
Dialogue on future of Agriculture well
in advance of the next discussion on the
next seven years budget and next debate
on the on the future cap and I believe
that through that strategic dialogue and
also with your participation we will
have plenty uh of the ideas how to
structure and frame those
policies better and I agree with Mr
Alvarez that we have to work with the
with the farmers because they have to
feel the ownership of this process and
this is how the structured strategic
dialogue is organized Madame
Miller uh was uh referring to the
importance to make sure that the
Strategic dialogue shouldn't just be a
top- down approach and I totally agree
with her and uh therefore we made sure
the participation in this this
discussion is wide raging that we have a
big farmers small farmers young Farmers
organic farmers that we have a
representatives of the whole value chain
researchers in innovators but also
academicians and I very much appreciate
that some of you suggested that it would
be good uh to also discuss these issues
on the regional level and I can assure
you that through the special portal
which we created for this we are ready
to accommodate also the ideas coming
from you coming from reg dialogue so
they would enrich the the final uh
report which will present to all of you
by the end of summer as a result of this
strategic dialogue I also agree uh with
you honorable members uh that the best
quality food in the world is produced
here in Europe and that our farmers are
guaranteeing not only the food security
for all Europeans but that also created
the sector about about which we are
proud because it's important parts of
the European economy and we want to
improve it further because uh uh the
European Farmers must consolidate this
important position for now and for the
future Madame
car had several discussions with them
and indeed we have to uh find the
solution to the two prevailing Pro
problems they've been highlighting to me
access to land and access to Finance if
you want to have young Farmers to work
on the farms we have to address these
two issues and it's one of the topic
which we are discussing together many of
you called for better use of our
regional policies to make sure that our
rural areas have a good schools have a
good internet have a good digital and
transport infrastructure because it's
important part uh for our Farmers to be
efficient and for young Farmers to be of
course attracted into this profession
and we take it on board we are working
on it and also with my colleague
commissioner responsible
for regional de development Madame fera
we are really paying a lot of attention
to this issue I think in every
intervention
today was a call for reduction of
bureaucracy and uh
simplification and uh again we hear you
loud and clear and uh we have to work
again on this together on the European
level I'm glad that many of you also C
that we have to tackle the gold plating
on the national level sometime the
specific Regional uh problems by
application of the European law and just
uh to make sure that we will we will
limit the bureaucracies to the to the
minimum it's clearly priority for our
commission our president is paying
enormous attention to this and uh um
together with the cluster of the green
deal Commissioners uh we are working to
make sure that we will also deliver on
these very important priorities I also
would like to thank the honorable
members who made clear reference uh for
tackling the unfaired Trade Practices
and proper implementation of uh the
directive on unfair Trade Practices we
completely share your uh objective and
we are working on making sure that this
would be well enforced currently we are
at stage where we are assessing how this
is enforced and implementing across the
member states to make sure that it's
uniform it's working it delivers and of
course it brings the results uh which we
need uh to remove unfair Trade Practices
from uh
agriculture there was also quite a lot
of U intervention focused on the ongoing
negotiations on the trade uh agreements
and here again I would like to be uh
clear and following this uh debate I
would like to confirm uh that um uh
commission assessment is that the
conditions for the conclusion of
mercosur agreement are not
met and to conclude Madame President
thank you very much for your Indulgence
but the debate was very very long and I
uh wanted to uh respond to as many
inquir is is possible I would like to
conclude by reassuring you that we in
the commission feel the sense of urgency
and we act the Strategic dialogue and
intensive interaction with our Farmers
uh Community is
ongoing and if you ask about the
concrete steps just look at the last two
weeks I would just recall our proposal
on the partial uh derogation of guy gate
uh which is on the U on the living uh
land follow obligation where we work
with the flexibilities and I believe
that together with the Belgian
presidency we will find a good solution
for our Farmers the same applies to the
import agriculture imports from Ukraine
where we do our utmost to make sure that
Ukrainian exports will go to the
original destinations in the third
countries and if that would not be uh
possible that we will protect our
farmers were and when necessary and the
last word Madame President honorable
members I would recall
again and uh if you allow me to pass it
through our honorable members to our
Farmers community so dear Farmers we
respect you we value your work and I
believe that we will overcome these uh
challenges which are ahead of us today
together thank you very much Madame
President
thank you let me now give the floor to
the council please Mrs
La thank you very much president
commissioner
sovich members of the parliament thank
you very much indeed first and foremost
for this debate which I've listened to
with great interest I've taken careful
note of your comments and your
suggestions there are a few key points
which will be Central to my policy
in the future agriculture environment go
hand in hand the one can't evolve
without the other and the farmers of
course see at firsthand the impact of
climate change and are at the same time
on the front line in terms of impact we
also have to look at the issues of
intensive cultivation and see that this
too will have an impact on them and if
we don't have a farming sector we won't
have a planet therefore agriculture
envir enironment and the energy
transition have all got to come together
and we need to make sure that we support
the farmers and assist them through all
the necessary transitions with the
support that they need they are key to
us we need food security they need a
fair market they need rules which govern
the game they need more Europe a more
flexible agile Europe and one which
better reflects the daily reality within
which they work as commissioner shovi
has just said the farmer need the
farmers need the EU and the EU needs
Farmers the free trade agreements have
also been Central to our debates Farmers
have to be able to export to New Markets
to diversify but once again not to their
detriment and the council is Keen to see
the updated studies on the impact of the
trade agreements and the farm
sector once we get this we will have
better insights into the real impact of
trade agreements on our
the full detail of our debate to clar
Deval who'll be chairing the next
Agriculture and Fisheries policy um
Council on the 26th of February thank
you very much for your
attention thank you Minister laib that
concludes that debate and our work
continues with the this is Europe debate
with the the president of Romania CL
Yannis thank
you
e